إذن هذا هو السؤال الذي تقول مغنية الراب نيكي ميناج
أن صديقة ابنة عمها وقد
نشرت هذا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي لديها 22
مليون متابع ،
قالت إنه أصيب بتورم في الخصيتين بعد
أخذ اللقاح الذي أشارت إليه في
الواقع باعتباره أحد الأسباب التي تجعلها لم تفعل ذلك
بعد.  تلقيت التطعيم ، تدعي
أنها ليست ضد اللقاح لكنها
تقول إنها تريد إجراء المزيد من الأبحاث ،
ماذا تقول لسانجاي
حسنًا ،
لذا فإن صديق ابن عمها الذي لديه
السحلب هو المصطلح الطبي
للخصيتين المتورمتين أم
تعلمون ليس لدي شك في ذلك
هذا شيء حدث
لهذا الفرد وليس لدي شك أيضًا
أنه لا علاقة له
باللقاح ، أعني أن هذا هو الشيء
الذي يجعل الكثير من الأشخاص
لديهم هؤلاء ، أنت تعلم أنك حصلت على 32
بالمائة من  دولة ترينيداد التي تم
تلقيحها ، سيكون لديك
أشخاص لديهم مشكلات مصاحبة مع
اللقاح لا علاقة
لها باللقاح ، لذا لا أعتقد أن هذه
مشكلة.  سوف تقرأ عن
هذا اللقاح المسبب لالتهاب الخصية أو
الخصيتين المتورمتين ، وهذا ليس
شيئًا يدعو للقلق الآن من
حيث الضعف الجنسي أو أنك تعرف
مشاكل الخصوبة التي كانت فكرة خاطئة
تقريبًا منذ طرح اللقاحات أه
هناك كل الأنواع المختلفة  أنت
تعرف الأسباب التي جعلت هذا المفهوم خاطئًا
ولكن هناك الكثير من الدراسات
تقول نيكي ميناج إنها تريد إجراء بحثها ،
وهناك الكثير من الأبحاث هناك ،
حيث بحثت المجلة الطبية الأمريكية على
وجه التحديد في قضايا الخصوبة
ولم تجد مشاكل الخصوبة
لديك تقريبًا  200 مليون شخص الآن
تلقوا اللقاحات في الولايات المتحدة ،
مليارات الأشخاص حول العالم ، هذه
ليست مشكلة لذا فأنت تعلم أنني
أقدر رغبتها في إجراء
البحث ، إنه موجود أه أتمنى
لصديق ابن عمها التوفيق ولكن هذا ليس كذلك
مرتبط باللقاح ، فقد يكون مرتبطًا
بنوع آخر من العدوى التي كان من
الممكن منعها بواسطة اللقاح ولكن
ليس cov  ولقاح 19